all right baldacci
sir maldochi uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally i'm from
uh los angeles uh florence district
south los angeles basically that's what
it basically is
and tell me uh about your family growing
up yeah mom and dad yeah um yeah my mom
and dad um you know they're born here as
well
uh i was born actually at the hospital
centennial hospital in the city of
inglewood and from that hospital i was
took to a street called city uh converse
that's why i got this converse all-star
tattoo because i'm an all-star actually
from the block you know i mean
um
growing up you know my mom was basically
the main person in the home because my
father he was in prison for a long time
gone and
you know so it was a little bit you know
harder for me uh being the fact that you
know my father was gone i'm not gonna
blame that totally on
you know him being gone me being
what i am today or everything that i
live is because of that um but it's
definitely hard without a father figure
in the home yeah what was that in prison
for um he was my dad was in prison for a
bunch of robberies you know growing up
that's i guess was he in a gang yeah my
dad was also from florence uh as well uh
my brothers my sisters basically all of
us except for my mom mom was the one
that
stuck to working two jobs to try to you
know feed us and keep us
you know in a straight line but at the
end of the day it's like you know you
you
you go for what you want to do it's not
you know
how far are you in school
um i actually got a ged but i did uh get
my ged through
the prison system
um on the streets i went to maybe like
seventh seventh grade maybe eighth grade
and then it was basically i went to
juvenile hall from there like i was a
kid
gone like you know what i mean i was
living the streetlights so the gang
stuff started for you early uh 13 years
old
you know i was being intrigued by the
lifestyle and kind of
uh amazed by it and
just basically went you know went at it
went towards it instead of actually
trying to live a different life like
that was
what was in my
in my future i guess you know the idea
of being uh
anything else in life um coming to your
head
like honestly at a young age i didn't
really think about no career i really
didn't think about what i wanted in the
future i really didn't think about my
future to be honest with you it was just
day for day that i was living
um
that's that's what happened basically i
ended up you know you're down in
florence which yeah florencia is one of
the most notorious gangs
yeah that's where that's where i'm from
you know um
basically
like i said at a young age
that's that's what caught my attention
and that's what i ended up you know
becoming a part of how it didn't take
long for you to go to prison um no i
mean it's it took as long as me to turn
the legal age to go you know what i mean
like i at the end of the day like i
started going to juvenile halls real
young at the age of 13 14
going in and out you know my first time
going i actually juvenile hall sounds
nice but it's actually just jail for
kids right right that's a jail for kids
you know once i've seen that it wasn't
actually as bad as the way people make
it seem
you know like growing up they're like oh
this and this and this happens which it
probably does to certain individuals
that allow that to happen
uh myself
you know i went in
with somebody else as well with me and
we kind of like you know he he put me up
on game
on our way to juvenile hall
hey you know what this is what you got
to do don't be scared
you know just do your thing and i did
and i kind of like i said i learned that
it wasn't as bad as the way people
explained it
if you don't allow that to take place is
jail and later in life prison kind of
like a rite of passage for you guys uh
what do you mean is it just like a badge
of honor um i mean at the end of the day
it's like you know everybody
like growing up
in this lifestyle myself i don't want to
speak for everybody but myself i kind of
looked up to like
i wanted to go just to experience
you know what everybody else is you know
they say you know you get home
you get a lot of love you get a lot of
respect you get you know
it's just it's something that i kind of
like
spoke into existence or just actually
just walked in to
get walked into it being part of you
know my lifestyle who were your role
models as a kid my dad my dad was my
role model but he was he was in prison
yeah he was in prison but he was still
my role model you know my dad you know
as far as i can remember my dad would
send
letters
but my dad would encourage me to stay
away from
life to stay away from the gangs and you
know don't get myself caught up and for
me to listen to my mom like
he didn't sit there and try to make me
be part of the gang or join the that
lifestyle but at the end of the day it's
like
you can't tell somebody
to do something when
you did it yourself or you're in that
position like so i can remember my dad
sending drawings home from prison
sending us cups you know with artwork on
the cups tupperware like
and all that you know was was
fascinating to me all that was really
like intriguing
so i i you know
and i didn't even have to go look for it
like it just basically came to me
what was your what was your first
gang activity as a young kid what'd you
get into um so like at the beginning you
know me growing up 13 years old i ended
up getting caught for three stolen
vehicles and one day
it's funny because you know
um i got caught basically it was like
breakfast lunch and dinner i got caught
early in the morning for you know
joyriding being in a stolen car
at that age
they know that you're a kid and you're
you know bound to be getting in trouble
so they released me to like the custody
of my mom you know she had to pick me up
or whatnot on the scene actually like
they didn't even take me to the station
nothing it was basically get your son
get out of here
lunch time again i was arrested for
another stolen vehicle um and again they
basically kicked me out to my mom and to
you know here get your son keep him off
the streets punish him do whatever you
got to do but we don't want to see him
out here again
my mom took me home and you know at the
end it was night time you know somebody
called me up hey bro like you know can
you go with me to go pick up my aunt oh
and this and that i'm like yeah i got
you whatever so i jump in the car with
them
thinking everything's cool and there'll
be another stolen car and i end up going
to jail this time the cops pull up mom
gets there they told her luck just go
home he's going to jail so this time i
ended up going to juvenile hall i didn't
stay there that long but it was my
entrance to
seeing what the juvenile system was like
how much time have you spent in
bars that time or just like or just in
your whole life
i've pretty much been in
incarcerated
more than half of my life
so i just been
in and out
doing the halls camps every every
everything i just touched basically a
lot of different places what's more
treacherous for you uh the streets or or
prison um i think like
the streets and and prison are basically
the same except for the streets you have
more space
you know the um prison system it's a lot
more closed
so it's like
you
you can't get around the way you get
around out here on the streets you know
what i mean it's just a different it's a
different atmosphere
but still basically the same like
everything anywhere you go the streets
is dangerous prison is dangerous like
you know being the fact like prison it
can go from you having
a year left on your time and you could
end up doing the rest of your life in
there something just ends up happening
you know
what what kind of
craziness have you gotten into in the
streets
yeah i actually got shot when i was 18
years old
i had barely turned 18 years old i was
shot five times with an ak-47
uh i was in a coma for two months
um
man i have like a missing spleen a
missing kidney i had like a half a
pancreas half a liver both my lungs
collapsed my aorta was torn
um
one of the nurses came in when i first
got shot and wanted to take off like the
two like not the tubes but uh
the like attachments that i had
basically on me and she said oh we're
going to walk you i want to walk you and
i was like i couldn't talk cause i had a
tube in my mouth tube in my throat like
on my side and
i'm like trying to explain to her like i
can't walk yet you know i'm not ready to
walk she didn't listen to me but like i
said i couldn't talk so basically it was
like one of these
like no trying to explain to her she
didn't listen she followed up kept
taking off everything
sat me up and when she sat me up a air
bubble rushed to my head and i passed
out i basically died in front of them uh
the doctor came in brought me back said
that i was purple or blue or whatever
once he brought me back you know they
asked me to move like a certain part
side of my body honestly i kind of get
confused or like it's hard for me to
remember what side but it was like one
of my sides i was paralyzed from either
my right side or my left side but what
he did was say like oh move your right
hand so i moved it move your right leg i
moved it then he went to like hey move
your left arm and your left leg and i
couldn't
like it wouldn't budge
so what they had to do was basically uh
take me to the long beach memorial
hospital they put me in a diver's tank
where i was at an angle
um
i remember them putting a like uh they
had like a roll tv they rolled over the
tank where they put on the movie like i
think it was something about mary or
something like that they put the movie
on within five minutes i was out i was
gone sleeping so i guess they i don't
know if they gassed the thing or they
what it is that they do but they put you
to sleep
uh they brought me out again he told me
to move
move your right hand move your right leg
and i was able to and move the other
side and i couldn't so they put me back
in
the second time they brought me out i
was able to move my right and my left
both sides so basically they popped that
air bubble that went to my brain
um due to the fact that i don't know if
it was because of how fast she sat me up
or whatever it was i was not ready
to do what she wanted me to do which was
walk you know and um yeah i thank god i
was able to
you know overcome that and i'm able to
move both my hands both my legs now and
you know i'm still i'm still here yeah
did you ever consider
the fact that you know the doctors and
nurses worked so hard to save you
and they were
successful only to have you go back on
the streets and
probably reoffend right you know at the
moment it's it's so crazy because at the
moment you know i had my people coming
in to visit me at the hospital uh one of
my friends you know he had a low rider a
nice really nice car that i would always
tell them oh let's go cruising but he
would always be like oh you know i'm
busy or this and that he came to see me
and he's like hey bro when you get out
we're going to go cruising in my car
and i told them no
because my mind was like i can't
you know i have to get home and survive
now you know but
it didn't go as planned i got out and i
actually i feel like i kind of got worse
after that because i felt like
okay the banana clip didn't drop me you
know what can what could stop me now
like let's go and it just man it turned
into a world of
of trouble after that you know what i
mean not necessarily after that but just
it continued i kept on with my lifestyle
i didn't
just say hey i'm you know throwing in
the towel i'm giving up or
nah it's like i feel like it kind of
made me
made me an angry person
you know it escalates doesn't it for
sure like it just after that you know i
went to prison right after that i wasn't
even home for like
long enough to do basically anything i
was in a wheelchair for a little bit one
of my friend's uh wife's actually came
to my house
to put a sheet around me because the
doctor said i was going to be paralyzed
you're not going to be able to walk
um
that was a lie because i'm walking you
know
my boy's uh wife came through
out after the wheelchair we went from
she her picking me up tying the sheet
around me kind of taking baby steps to
that went to like two days and then went
into a walker i walked on the walker for
a couple days
then i was up and running
you know and i ended up uh getting
caught for a pistol
uh sending sent to prison um
yeah that was my that was the beginning
basically of
my prison term
was me uh getting caught with a gun i
ended up taking a
six-year joint suspension which
basically means those six years stay
over your head
uh if you catch another case that's my
attorney explained to me if i caught
another
felony case i'll go do the six years
plus whatever that felony carry
that's not how it happened
i ended up getting a tattoo on my throat
which is this f-13 year
and they gave me six years for the
tattoo
so i didn't even have to catch a felony
to go do those six years which i was
expecting
you got time for a tattoo i got six
years
originally the time is for the gun
you know and that's how they look at it
like you're not doing time for that
you're doing time for the gun that we
basically gave you that joint suspension
for so
my tattoo i was on uh gang supervision
probation
i guess that was a violation you know
they came to my house they found
sweaters
that had my gang on it pictures of
myself and you know other people my
homies and
they ended up yeah if you have florencia
and f-13 all over your body you're
you're asking for trouble yeah and at
the end of the day it's like i mean i'm
filled up with tattoos like it didn't
stop me because i went and did that time
and while i was doing that time i got
more tattoos you know i filled up
basically my body you know what i mean
but being a kid i you know i went in
young and
i feel like it was basically the right
time for me to go anyways you know at
the end of the day like i
i learned i sat there and and worked out
got myself in shape
uh
yeah basically like it was it was
a blessing and a curse at the same time
i feel you know what what is behind all
the violence and
the typical gang behavior is it just the
testosterone and young men that yeah i
feel like you know people are caged up
you know what i mean they're they're
they're mr families they miss their
girlfriends they're they're um some
people have 25 years some people have 18
years but even on the street oh on the
street like even on the street you know
um where's this come from all this game
it's it's it's hard to say i feel like
you know
this is stuff that's been
happening way before us so once you join
you basically earn that hate
towards the next person
that's been
going at it with your homies or they're
going at it with these people and like
especially if somebody hurts one of my
people like one of my boys that i grew
up with
you you earned you basically it just
is it just human nature were meant to be
in packs um
i feel i kind of feel that way at the
end of the day i feel like you know even
watching national geographic you see the
way the lions move they move
with their with their squad of
who they you know i i recently watched i
can't i really can't remember the name
but it's it's about these lions they
don't they basically they're brothers or
whatever whatnot and they move together
and
fight fight fight till the end for
territory for
just everything you know what i mean
like food survival
you know so at the end of the day i feel
like
that
it might
have to be like that for everybody
yeah sometimes i think it's just human
nature too right
it just comes whether you're a country
or a street gang doesn't matter yeah
like it just
just comes with it what was your
favorite childhood memory
um
my favorite childhood memory would
probably be with my grandfather he
passed away he was a good man
um
him and my grandma were married for
i don't know 40 50 years or whatnot
uh he was a really really really good
person
he would
if we would see a bike that we wanted
on the street like somebody a kid with
it we didn't have it to where i could
say hey go buy me that bike
but what my grandfather would do would
drive off in his truck because he was
real hands-on building he can make you
whatever you basically wanted he could
fix any car
uh
he was just a beast with
his hands
um
he would drive
get in his truck drive around find a
bike
frame that's just sitting in the alley
or sitting on the street he would take
that go home sand it go to the bike shop
buy wheels whatever
pieces to the bike that he needed he
would make sure he gets them when i
would get home from school if i told him
this morning oh look i like that bike
he wouldn't say anything oh yeah it's
nice me oh boom we get to the school
go to school
when i get home that bike would be
sitting
there
you know like
maybe not the same exact bike but it
looked damn near similar really close
and he was the one to make that happen
like that always will remain with me and
all the stuff that he basically
embedded in our heads which was positive
more positive than
anything else because he was like i said
he was a really good man
my grandfather rest in peace do you have
kids
yes i have three kids
were you around to raise them um so
like the only one i got to actually seen
born was my middle son his name is music
don
i was home
i was with the girl at the time like
relationship wise when he was born so i
was in the hospital i got to cut the
cord like everything that took place
with with him being born i named him i
named him music don
so um
he he's basically like my only son that
i was able to see being born
my firstborn um i hit the system when
his mom was pregnant like a week week
pregnant you know like so i had to
actually see him
being born basically while i was in the
system
um
my last kid is my daughter um
she's still a baby she's uh
you know four years old going on five
years old or whatnot she uh
i didn't get to see her born because we
were dealing with a whole bunch of
you know relationship problems and it
got it got kind of bad with the whole
separation or whatnot but um
yeah you know i i try
whatever i can to be in in you know my
children's life one of them was taken
away from me basically from mother like
just basically left and haven't heard
anything from them but they're my kids i
love my kids to death you know and
i feel like you know it took my son my
oldest son a little while to realize
whatever is going on with their mothers
and myself is not
doesn't have anything to do with them
you know and my son once he was able to
say hey i want to meet my dad like not
meet him but basically i want to see my
dad i want to be around my dad
then the mother basically was put in a
position to where
there's nothing she could say but say
hey here you know so
you know i have a relationship with them
um a few like two of my kids i haven't
really been you know seen them as much
as i would want to or as much as i
should be but
you know i feel like i said with my
oldest son he kind of realized i need to
see my dad you know so
i kind of let him let them sort out
their selves you know instead of me
trying to put pressure or hey this or
blame each other or it's
i'm over that you know
what's what's been the hardest thing
you've had to deal with in your life
um my health
um i want to say my health dealing with
my health is is just definitely been a
bumpy you know road from a gunshot from
the gunshots that you know later on just
you know it's been a long time since i
got shot but at the end of the day i
still have
complications and you know deal with
certain stuff that i'm have that i'm i
have to go to the hospital for certain
things at certain times so i want to say
that's probably been the hardest for me
i'm sure you've inflicted some of the
same kind of pain on other people
you know i mean growing up as a kid it's
like so much stuff happens you know and
at the end of the day it's like i'm not
proud of anything like i'm not you know
people
people fight for their for their you
know for their people for their you know
streets or you know what i mean so it's
it's been like i said a bumpy road both
sides you know what i mean at the end of
the day like
i'm here still i'm alive you know and
that's that's the that's the blessing
the good part of it you know live by the
sword and die by the sword it's it's
crazy man do you believe in karma
oh yeah i believe i believe in karma i
believe you know i just feel like
it it can it doesn't have to be the same
thing if you do something to somebody
that doesn't have to the karma doesn't
have to hit you back the same way it
could be in a different form absolutely
you know what i'm saying you could be
put in jail for something you didn't do
and that's your karma for something you
did i think you carry around the
subconscious guilt right and you're just
waiting for
you're going to do something to bring it
yeah at the end of the day it's like you
know what i mean stuff happens for a
reason i feel you know
you ever you ever wonder what your life
would have been like if you'd grown up
in like
connecticut or kansas or something like
that i actually grew up in one of the
most dangerous parts of la right yeah i
grew up in south la so you know like
it's it's kind of hard to picture
growing up somewhere else only because
that's all i really knew that's all i
really know
you know have you ever left l.a um
to be in prison basically that's that's
the only time i really left and
and lived anywhere else pretty much no
like that's where i've been since i was
a kid like
um there's a whole world out there right
you know what i mean it's like i feel
like i just wonder if you like as a kid
if you had traveled to europe or right
asia or something i've never really
traveled until basically now that i'm a
little bit older that you know
like i do i do music and whatnot so now
i'm able to
to get out a little bit and enjoy
other parts of
what's here you know like i i
never had the opportunity before because
i was
young and like i said involved in
everything that was going on in my area
so at the end of the day it's like i
didn't have time for anything else other
than that you know
are there i'm gonna go back to the karma
conversation we just had
are there are there things that you've
done that you take with you as you put
your head on a pillow at night
um that you uh i mean i feel like
everything that's been done in my life
you know i i like i said i started
really young and i got myself in a lot
of trouble i feel like i i've paid
for a lot of the things that i've done
and
it's like
now
that i'm on a better track and trying to
focus in on on myself and a better me
i feel like
i've done basically my time for that
i've suffered
from being shot and living that
lifestyle and now it's like
it's a i don't want to say a fresh start
because that's always going to stay with
you like the way you look the way you
grew up it's always going to stay you
know i mean that's not going away but
if you ask me i'm a better person today
i'm able to
wake up and you know i'm not going to
sit here and say i i just go wherever i
want because like i said again look at
the way i look streets
they don't care if you feel like you're
changing or doing a better better deed
in life
stuff still happens so i still watch
myself i still carry myself with
the mentality that i grew up with is to
keep myself in in line and
you know safe
yeah i mean you must know when you're
getting all these face tattoos of
i brought that upon myself on yourself
yeah and you you knew that was coming no
for sure and i feel like you know i
started young with the tattoos on my
face
as a kid i was you know 13. i was 14 i
believe when i put my first tattoo on my
chin i had a f-13
um
they just kept on and i felt like it
wasn't did you explain what f13 fs f13
is florence you know that's what
thirteen's potential that's what i was
yeah it's that's the gang total like f13
florence you know so
what 13 is what it's it's it's it's our
number you know our number like 13
signifies uh uh
mexico right south like us the south
yeah
okay right so
we um
basically
you know
i feel like the tattoos kept going like
i wanted more i wanted more and i i
wanted to stand out from everyone else i
didn't want to look like
the next guy i wanted myself to be
different and you know little by little
it was like oh i need one here this one
don't look right it looks empty here
this needs to match this siding bro look
how i look now you know it's like i
i went through a whole bunch of pain
getting these tattoos and a lot of them
were in prison so you know a lot of
people are like damn when i step into
certain places they're like how much
have you spent on tattoos money-wise and
i'm like a couple cases of soups
a couple you know bags of beans some
rice you know like like in prison it's
like we look out for each other
you do my whole back tattoo bro and i
got you i'll send you a package that's
exactly how i got my whole tattoo done
one of the homies that the tattoos he
didn't have much
he was like hey you know you bless me
and i'll bless you like he got he had
really good work
so i had him do my whole back i sent him
a package i reached out to my family hey
can you send this person a package
you know it had roast beef cans
deodorant soaps whatever it was that he
needed he gave me a list of the stuff he
needed and i got it from in prison in
prison yeah you know because we were
able to get packages at that time
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your life
um how old are you um i'm 40 now i just
turned 40 a couple days ago
right i would say
the most important thing in life is what
what you've learned in life um trust
it's like trust
is i'm really big on trust you know it
has to be basically earned
um
it's hard to trust anyone now you know
your closest people
your any anybody can basically turn on
you you know females that you deal with
i've dealt with females that you know
now it seems like they're my enemies and
at one time in life me and you were
tight you were my best friend i i did
this for you you did that for me
since it didn't work out
now we're enemies and it's like it
shouldn't be like that you know at the
end of the day it's like okay things
didn't work out work out there's a lot
more people in this world that you can
go try to find someone
a lot is made of how men are
violent and dangerous and all that but i
think women can be just as scandalous
and treacherous oh yeah especially
nowadays before i feel like the women
were a little bit different a lot of the
like you know my sister my mom
they're different from the women that
are out today and i can see that you
know what i mean like i noticed that why
because i've been with women back then
and i've been with women now and i see
the difference and the change in them
which i understand that they've probably
been through a lot dealing with men
dealing with abusive people like you
know that's one thing i've never done
and i'll never do is put my hands on a
female i learned that from my dad you
know my dad
his exact words would be
if if you hit a [ __ ] what does that
make you
excuse my language but that's that was
his words to me and it made a lot of
sense to me it stayed with me you know
i'm like you hit somebody that's this
like not low but females
they don't have the strength we have
they don't have
you know
the the testosterone that a man has it's
different you know god made them
different from us for a reason they're
feminine and i feel like you know you
put your hands on a woman then you lower
yourself under that you're feminine
you know but
to each his own people do it
hey if that's how you were you know
raised or brought up or you feel like
you need to let out your
your anger i mean i'm not here to stop
anybody from doing anything anyways but
if it comes down to that myself i don't
agree on that you know like
and i won't ever do it
has the gang
presence or the gang life
deteriorated since you were younger
um i mean i want to say like over the
years things change different different
uh
times you you were around during the
drive-by era yeah i've been around i've
been around since my when i when i
joined i was uh
13 that was like
um
maybe like 95 96 so all that was
basically kind of
toning down already but
it
was around like you know what i mean
stuff like that did happen you know what
i mean and it was
it was rough
it was rough growing up in that in that
time yeah
how has it changed now um
i i want to say just
the the the generation of people
um
the
solidness the um
trust again is is
completely different you know a lot of
integrity
yes i would say that too i just feel
like you know um
i'm not saying that all the generation
now is tore up or messed up or
there's still solid people that you know
what i mean but it's just like a lot of
what goes on now is not
what probably would have been going on
back then and it's just i mean i can't
even pinpoint and say this this this
that it's just there's so much
difference you know
have you mellowed with age um like calm
down basically yeah i i'd say a lot like
um
you know
with my music career now like i kind of
want to
do that like and you know the good thing
about it is that my people my friends my
homies that i grew up with
respected and appreciated and pushed me
to do that
instead of you know people looking down
on you hey like you're not trying to
be out here doing this and that like
people are more for it and willing to
help me
get further by
oh hey you know what look we got
these cards you can use for your music
video we got you know these girls that
you you know maybe put this girl in your
video like that type of stuff it's like
encouraging and motivating and i'm
really
you know blessed to have that
that you know that and people embrace
that you know like it's it's hard
to actually be that way a lot does it
feel
good to be creating something that maybe
helps someone in some way with music
your music yeah than what you used to do
you know like it's
i assume you're still active but you're
just like well like i kind of look at it
like it's not even about the activeness
because my face and my the way i look is
gonna have me
in that box forever for the rest of my
life
you know
i'm not out there running around acting
a full getting in trouble no more if
that's what's what we're asking uh
but
i'm still me
i'm still good with my homies they love
me i love them you know what i'm saying
uh
i feel like with my with my music that i
do now i give a message
a lot of i went to jail on a violation
my probation officer basically violated
me and said that hey you know what he
did an album he wasn't supposed to be
doing the album he talked about
his gang or whatnot basically he made it
seem like i was promoting the gang
lifestyle um
i look at it like i'm telling my story
so at the end of the day
it's not about promoting or glorifying
or doing this i'm speaking my story of
everything that i've been through and
it's up to the kids nowadays to take
that message
and say hey
this is what i gotta go through if i
wanna live like this
or
i don't wanna live like this i wanna do
the right thing and stay away from
getting shot five times with an ak i
wanna stay away from going to prison
forever you know it's like and it took
me years to be able to
to learn this you know what i mean at
the end of the day it's like okay i
lived
a rough life
now
it's like i want
to be able to bless other people with
that knowledge that i didn't really have
growing up
to know that there's
other outlets there's ways to you know
what i mean maneuvering and still live
and enjoy your life
so with all these face tattoos what kind
of reactions do you get from people when
you walk into a liquor store or grocery
store or something like that it's it's
actually a trip i like this question
because
so many times i've gotten i mean i get
both i get negative and positive
faces from different people and the way
people look at me
the good thing about it is me seeing
their expression once they talk to me
once they see who i am once they see
i'm not what they think
it's a it's a beautiful feeling because
it's like okay you thought you were
gonna hear this or when people reach out
to me on social media and they're like
hey and i respond they're like i didn't
think you were gonna respond or i
thought you were gonna be mean or i
thought you know and i'm like i'm just
like you you know what i mean i got
tattoos okay cool you know there's just
like some people born
you know a certain way a certain color a
certain anything we're all
human at the end of the day and it's
like it's a blessing once they get to
you know interact with me and
communicate with me it's it's it's a
beautiful thing to see the
the change in
from five minutes ago
[Music]
all right baldacci thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you so much i
appreciate you for having me mark i wish
you the best of luck thank you sir thank
you appreciate it
you